في اثناء انتقلت احزاب احزاب وقوه سياسيه
عده في باكستان قرار حزب انصاف سحب نوابي
من البرلمانات المحليه في الاقاليم
الاربعه التي تشكل الفيدراليه الباكستانيه
وعرب كل من حزب الرابطه وحزب الشعب الذين
يشكلان مع تسعه احزاب اخرى التحالف الحاكم
حاليا في باكستان
استعداد نوابهما لتشكيل حكومه المحليه
بديله في اقليم خيبر
السلطات الامنيه في الوقت ذاته خففت حالته
بعناصرها في مدينه يروى الهندي المجاوره
للعاصمه وفتحت اربعه من المداخل الرابطه
بين المدينتين بعد اغلاقها لمده ثلاثه
ايام وكان زعيم حزب انصاف قد اعلن امس
تراجعه عن قياده مسيره حزبه صوب العاصمه
تجنبا لوقوع حاله اضطراب العامه حسب
تعبيره
ومن اسلام اباد مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد
الرحمن مطار اهلا بك عبد الرحمن اذا واضح
ان يعني عمران خان قدم شيئا من التنازل
بانه طلب انصره بايقاف المظاهره التي كان
يعد لها ولكن في المقابل لم تخف لهجته
ابدا ما زال يهاجم وينتقد بقوه
ايضا احداث نوع من انواع الفراغ السياسي
او الارباك السياسي هنا في باكستان لاسيما
مع اعلانه عن قرب استقاله بحزبه من
البرلمانات المحليه في الاقاليم الاربعه
وبالتالي خساره حزبه للحكم في اقليمين هما
اقليم خيبر واقيم البنجاب بالتاكيد هذا تم
بانه سيتسبب النوع من انواع الفراغ
السياسي في هذين الاقليمين على الاقل حيث
يحكم حزب الانصاف لكن الحكومه في المقابله
والتحالف الحزب الحاكمه الذي يعقد اليوم
ويعقد غدا ايضا سلسله من اللقاءات للتبحث
فيما يمكن فعله في كيف يمكن تجنب
همم هذا الفراغ السياسي وكيف يمكن في
المقابل المصارعه الافشال الخطوه التي
يسعى عمران خان لاحداثه هناك حقيقه الكثير
من التحرك على المستوى السياسي في هذه
الاثناء ايضا حزب انصاف بزاعه عمران خانكم
علمنا سيعقد هذا اليوم في مدينه لور
الاجتماعي ايضا للتباحث فيما يتعلق
بالتوقيت استقاله نواب حزبه من البرلمانات
المحليه الكثير من التحرك السياسي في هذه
المرحله وايضا الكثير من التحسن على
المستوى الامني علمنا ايضا من مصادر
الامنيه بان حاله التاهب القصوى التي كانت
مفروضه على مدار الايام القليله الماضيه
قد خفت هذا اليوم الكثير من المنافذ
الرابط بين العاصمه ومدينه
اليوم وايضا الكثير من التخفيف الامني حتى
هنا في العاصمه الاسلام بعد مع ربما
تشاهدون كيف ان هذه المنطقه تحديدا كان
هناك الكثير من رجال الشرطه والقوات الدرك
وحتى من الشات شبه العسكريه التابعه
للحكومه الفيدراليه تم السحب معظم هؤلاء
السبعين الف عنصر امنيه الذين تم
التعذيذهم ونشر في ارجاء الاسلام بعد
ومحيط اسلام اباد تم تخفيفهم هذا اليوم في
محاوله ربما للتاكيد على ان الوضع الامني
قد تحسنا وان التهديد الامني قد خف بحسب
كثير من المصادر الامنيه هنا في الاسلام
بعد
مطار من اسلام اباد شكرا